[Music]
james want
license to kill
in love with madeleine swann
welcome to your weekly ticket fall
preview edition
this year's fall movie season is finally
here it's a season packed with things
like blockbusters and notable awards
contenders from things like lady gaga's
house of gucci to chloe zhao's eternals
and yes the long-awaited james bond film
no time to die we pulled over 1500 movie
fans to rank their most anticipated fall
movies of 2021
and here to help us break down the top
10 from that list is fandango
correspondent nikki novak nikki welcome
to the show
it has been so long kale how are you
i've been great but i want to know
everything about the top 10 from this
list
all right let's kick this list off with
number 10 encanto what can you tell us
about this nikki
well this is the next disney animated
film this is set in columbia it stars
stephanie beatriz she is best known for
brooklyn nine-nine and she plays a young
girl by the name of mirabelle and
mirabelle's family
all has magical powers she is the only
person in her family to not have any
abilities it frustrates her until those
magical powers in her family are
threatened and she may be the only one
that can save those abilities and save
her family so she thinks she's not
special but turns out she may be in a
much different way what's unique about
this disney animated film
yeah so this one is the first one that's
going to be set in colombia it's going
to feature afro-latino characters which
is a first for disney really show the
diversity of colombia some of the music
will be said in spanish some in english
but once again you have lin-manuel
miranda who wrote eight songs for the
film he is so incredible every time i
mean the songs from moana are still
stuck in my head but also carlos vivas
who is a colombian singer songwriter
also contributed to the music in this
film
coming in at number nine is dear evan
hansen nikki tell us about this one fans
of the musical are gonna be so excited
about this one it stars ben platt now
this was the biggest musical after
hamilton it won six tony awards
including best musical and best actor
for ben platt and he is going to be
reprising his role as a high school teen
who has social anxiety disorder and gets
caught in a web of lies
social media erupted by the way gail
when it was
the trailer came out because ben platt
is now 27 years old to me he still looks
like a teeny has that baby face but fans
are super excited about this one what
can they expect from the film one thing
that fans can look forward to is their
two new songs the songs are hugely
catchy and two new songs were written
just for the film as well ben has said
that the ending is going to be a little
bit different than the stage adaptation
he said that it's going to be extended
he said usually at the end of a stage
production people are ready to get out
of their seats so they really wanted it
to play out a lot more in this version
but you also have an all-star cast added
to uh the og which is ben platt you have
oscar winner julianne moore amy adams
amandla stenberg who is a breakout star
from the hate u give and caitlyn deaver
from book smart so this is a
star-studded cast now this is one of
many musicals that's coming out recently
we have in the heights we have west side
story so how is this one going to
separate itself from those
well number one i think this one uh it's
been described by ben platt as more of a
drama with music i mean you talk about
in the heights or you think about west
side story there are huge productions
with huge stage element to it and big
ensemble cast singing together this one
feels a lot more grounded um and a
little tidbit that came from set
apparently
one of the people working in the crew
after they saw the first musical number
performed for this film
they used an expletive and said this is
going to be a really good bleepin movie
so this one does uh really tell the
story of it's a comic of age story about
teens and growing up and very relatable
not only during this time for teens but
people of all ages
coming in at number eight is halloween
kills all right what can you tell us
about this one nikki
well kale this is the twelfth halloween
movie in the franchise but it is also
the second in a trilogy the last one
being in 2018 called halloween which of
course saw jamie lee curtis reprising
her role as lori strode fans were super
happy about that one
and apparently it's the second to last
of all time the lucky number 13th will
be called halloween ends and that would
will come out uh in the next couple
years
oh is it is it gonna end
never say you mean can you really ever
kill mike myers that is my question i
mean in this film they're kind of
teasing that look
he might not ever be able to be killed i
mean he's kind of um
he's an entity at this point he is pure
evil and jamie lee curtis has sort of
said that's kind of why this isn't
george she really thinks this is just a
good versus evil story at the end of the
day but she also said in this film where
in the last film we really focused on
her trauma on lori stewart's trauma 40
years of trauma by the way in this one
we're focusing on her rage and she's
getting together finally i don't know
why they never thought of this before
kayla why did they always wait
for
mike myers to descend on them on a
halloween and they sat in their little
houses and people trick-or-treated and
it might or might not be mike myers at
the door this time around the people of
haddenfield and jamie lee curtis and
laurie strode are going after mike myers
they're hunting him down they're going
to his childhood home so the hunter
becomes the hunted now that jamie lee
curtis is back
are there other original cast members
that are coming back too
well you also have
i
what sounds to me like two people
playing mike myers including nick castle
who is the og he is going to have some
sort of a role um in this film there are
two actors credited you also have james
jude courtney who played mike myers in
the last film um and they're both
credited as the shape as they are so i'm
you know how much each one will play uh
remains to be seen
oh wow okay you had me thinking it was
going to be like a spider-man into the
you know spider-burst thing we're going
to have two
two michael myers together from
different movies it could be and they
should just try to kill each other and
see what happens everyone is just trying
to do the marvel thing i get it i get it
it's fun
at number seven we have the last duel
mickey break this one down for us oh my
gosh
ben affleck and matt damon why have you
waited since goodwill hunting to write a
script together well they are finally
doing it with nicole hollof center she
also wrote can you ever forgive me she's
an oscar-nominated writer so the three
of them teamed up together and what's
cool about this is ben and matt wrote
the male parts in this movie and she
wrote the female part in this film the
female part by the way stars none other
than jody comer now this is a 14th
century medieval drama it was about the
last sanctioned duel in france so it is
based on a true story but you don't have
ben and matt dueling each other you have
the addition of one adam driver to the
cast he and matt damon played one time
best friends who are now adversaries
because jody comer's character has
accused her husband played by matt
damon's uh best friend of rape and this
is like i said based on a true story and
based on a 2001 novel of the same name
this is directed by ridley scott he has
two films coming out this fall and he's
working with adam driver twice i
actually really excited to see this one
at number six house of gucci nicky what
do you got for us on this one oh my gosh
the internet by the way i think it was
trending for like 25 days after this
trailer came out because there was so
much buzz this is lady gaga's first role
since the star is born it also stars
another internet uh favorite adam driver
as well as an unrecognizable jared leto
who had a lot of prosthetics for this
but here's what's really cool this is
based on the incredible story about
patricia reggiani who was convicted of
having her husband assassinated her
husband in the film is played by adam
driver and his name was maurizio gucci
and she was so upset about the way he
handled the house of gucci when he was
the head
that uh well legend has it and this is
disputed by her that she had him killed
now this is just an all-star cast also
stars jeremy irons in the film
but
i mean look for this during awards
season not only is it going to do box
office numbers but i think everybody i
think lady gaga has already nominated
for best actress at this point she
always should be she should be nominated
for every award all the time forever
yeah yeah now this is another ridley
scott film that's coming out this year
so which of the two that are coming out
this year are you the most excited about
well between the last duel
and
you know this film i think this film
wins the duel and in my opinion the fans
got it right i'm slightly more excited
about this one although you never
discount ben and matt but i mean this
one just has all it has murder it has
passion it has rage it has fashion what
more do you want it looks so different
from anything else coming out this fall
at number five venom let there be
carnage nikki what's going on in this
one i love tom hardy and i love him in
this role this is like the odd couple
that you never knew you needed you know
uh eddie brock being you know hosting
this alien symbiote named venom i mean
the the jokes between the two of them in
the last venom movie makes me want to
see this one except this one as in the
title we're adding a new character this
was teased in the last movie called
carnage played by woody harrelson who
uh eddie braga goes back and interviews
him if you remember he was a journalist
trying to revive his career and woody
harrison's character is the person he's
interviewing he is a serial killer who
was also infected by a symbiote so you
can imagine serial killer plus evil
entity infected it's not good it's not a
great combination
in the spider-man comics by the way
spider-man eventually teams up with
venom to kill carnage we'll see if this
could happen maybe in a future movie but
for now it's going to be venom and
carnage kind of going toe-to-toe in this
movie i'm super excited about woody
harrelson's performance so you have
naomi harris is also being added to the
cast she plays a character known also in
the comics as shriek she is woody
harrelson's carnage love interest and
this is sort of the development of
another new character in the spider-man
comics universe at number four
ghostbusters afterlife nikki what's
going on in this one oh my gosh
this is basically a continuation of the
first two ghostbusters movies from the
80s it is directed by jason reitman who
is the son of ivan reitman who directed
the og ghostbusters so talk about
keeping it in the family and paying
tribute to the original speaking of the
original a lot of the og cast members
are going to be back you're going to
have dan aykroyd zegorney weaver annie
potts are all back
but they are passing the torch to a new
generation of ghostbusters including
mckenna grace and finn wolford uh as
well as why not round it out with
another big superstar paul rudd is also
in the cast and it's about a young
family that moves to oklahoma where a
lot of strange occurrences take place
and they uncover that the grandfather of
this family was one of the original
ghostbusters and it goes from there by
the way this screamed already at
cinemacon earlier this year and people
are absolutely loving it they're saying
they just it just did it justice and
feels very spielbergy and whatever that
means all right so this is another
sequel now where does it fall in the
timeline with the first one the second
one and even the new the newer female
ghostbusters where is it is that does
that in there at all
well the first and to answer the
question about it's really a sequel uh
with a new generation so it takes place
in a normal timeline you know some 30
years after the events of the first two
ghostbusters but in terms of the female
lead ghostbusters film that came out
several years ago it exists in the same
universe jason reitman was asked about
it but he basically said they're not
really going to address those female
ghostbusters but it does exist in the
same universe considering some of the
original casts were in that film had
cameos in that film
yeah speaking of the original cast who
else is going to be in this one well
unfortunately harold ramus passed away
um and so he was one of the original
ghostbusters he won't be in this film
but uh they will pay tribute to him in
in the sense that this young family that
uncovers you know the ghostbusters car
and the ghostbusters machinery this
young family are the grandchildren of
the harold ramus character from the
original ghostbusters but like i said
annie passes back sigourney weaver um
and then as was seen in the trailer you
uh hear a phone you hear a phone call
and someone picks up the phone and it's
very clearly bill murray's uh voice so
they will be back as well and slimer's
back right
of course i think slimer's back yeah i
mean
stay puft marshmallow man
yeah but these tiny this time i think
they're tiny this time aren't they
they're like mini marshmallows yeah
they're good you can put them in cereal
number three
dune i'm very excited about this one i
haven't had a chance to read the books
yet so
what is it about what is dune about oh
my gosh purists of the novels would say
that was a question you should never ask
it is too complex to answer but i hear
that here is my attempt
it is about a young man who might be a
messiah played by timothy chalamet
who his family are shepherds of the
planet dune it is the only place in the
galaxy where they can harvest something
known as spicer melange which is
integral
to the species continuing and gives
superpowers how was that
i mean that sounds great i want to see
that also give me some of them spices
well if you want spice listen to the
rest of the cast number one we have
jason mamoa also in the cast zendaya
like i said timothy chalamet rebecca
ferguson and oscar isaac play the
parents of the timothy chalamet
character now george lucas said that the
novel dune inspired star wars so do you
think that this adaptation could lead to
multiple sequels and have its own
star wars series like size of movies
i mean i think it can in terms of the
there's the source material is there you
also have denny villanuev who is
directing this and he said before he
agreed to this film he said it would
have to be a two-parter so this first
film is only actually going to be the
first half of the book now he is also
denise let's just mention a rival blade
runner 2049 he is one of the best sci-fi
directors out there so provided i think
it sets the tone right who knows if he
would do more than the first two i think
what's different from dune and star wars
is star wars i think of the word hope
it's eternally hopeful this is a much
darker uh series and you know we want
the fans you got to give the fans what
they want i think that the purists and
the die hards are going to be excited
it's very sophisticated material though
jason momoa himself says this is a very
adult movie
so
you know it just depends on how if it's
explained in a way and and done in a way
that people can grab onto it all right
coming in at number two
it's finally almost here no time to die
tell us a little bit about it
daniel craig's fifth and final outing as
double-oh-seven bond james bond himself
or so he says look never say never or is
that about the title of a bond movie it
is
look
the big question here in this film and
his final outing is will he or won't he
and i mean what's in the title will he
or won't he die now this is the first
opportunity that the producers have ever
had to kill off a james bond character
given the fact that the actor announced
before the script was written for this
film that he was leaving the franchise
so i think you know all of the teasers
the trailers are kind of hinting at that
fact that leah sidoo who plays of course
madeleine swann who is his love will
cause his downfall um but here's what's
also exciting
rami malek sorry
oscar winner rami malek plays the lead
villain in this he plays safin as well
leshana lynch is a new double o um and
then of course you have all the uh
beloved characters and actors coming
back from the past few films
okay so assuming this is daniel craig's
last film
who would you like to see play bond next
well i'm gonna borrow an actor that we
just talked about i've said that tom
hardy would make the coolest bond
because look we're in 2021 i think the
last couple of bonds have been very
polished and i think tom hardy's a
little more rough around the edges he's
a true auteur as an actor i don't know
if he would be the best in terms of
press he tends to go rogue a little bit
but that's what i think would make him
so interesting he's so unpredictable as
an actor
i will also i'm going to throw out a few
other names idris elba idris albert and
idris elba he is so perfect and he has
that charm that suave he's proven
himself hobbs and shaw he can do the
physical part the action suicide squad
he proved that again
but they are also hinting the franchise
that they may go a little bit younger so
reggae john page
from bridgerton is being thrown around
and of course henry cavill who was
originally in the running to play james
bond when daniel craig was hired is also
being talked about any of those names
would make me happy kale any of those
names and coming in at number one
is marvel's eternals all right nikki
break it down for us i don't even know
where to begin with this movie ten new
major characters are going to be
introduced into the mcu
including actors angelina jolie salma
hayek bryan tyree henry who will play
the first gay superhero in the mcu kamal
nanjiani as well as lauren ridloff who
will be the first deaf superhero in the
mcu and this takes place
after the events of end game now the
eternals are an immortal group of aliens
they're an alien race that have been
living on earth for thousands of years
now why didn't they get involved
with the infinity stones or any of that
well that is going to be explained it
was sort of explained in the trailer
that they were told not to interfere now
this movie is teasing something called
the emergence basically the story of
this movie is that after the snap and
then after half of the population came
back
it created enough energy to cause
something called the emergence now that
has just been hinted at but kevin feige
has said that this is definitely opening
up phase four of the mcu in a way we
have never seen in that it's gonna delve
into a lot of the past of the mcu and a
lot of the creation of some of the
characters maybe even thanos's early
life and how a lot of
these different
entities came to be
which is cool in the sense that it also
sets up the future of the mcu it could
possibly set up a new mutants
spin-off as well as a lot of new
characters so the implications for this
movie are pretty heavy as well as as the
fact that is the first ensemble
superhero movie since end game yes phase
four is just it's got a lot of things
going on do we know when this is going
to take place within all of the new side
stuff that's going on
well it takes place right after the
events of endgame and the events of end
game and the snap and then half the
population coming back has some real
huge consequences for not only earth but
also
uh the future um in terms of this world
and this world building so it's really
going to
a lot of people are thinking that it's
going to go back and it's going to go
forward it's going to go back in time
and explain a lot of the things in the
mcu that we would love to have explained
and in doing so it'll set up a lot of
new worlds in world building as we enter
phase 4. super exciting so yeah so it
looks like that maybe at the end or
maybe a post credits will show the
merging with the whole uh multiverse
sort of thing
yeah i think you know i think it's gonna
set up and start to explain the
multiverse um so that we can be ready
for spider-man and whatever else is to
con you know dr strange next year and
all the other uh uh mcu movies that we
have down the pipeline all right nikki
well thank you so much for joining us
and counting down the top 10 most
anticipated movies of fall 2021
thank you so much for having me k i'll
see you next time all right see ya well
what is your most anticipated movie of
fall 2021 let us know in the comments
[Music]
you